the only thing better than snacking on
perfectly ripe strawberries in the
summer
is tossing them in some sugar and
spooning them over a tender biscuit
and velvety whipped cream today we're
going to make our favorite version
of strawberry shortcake
there's a variety of shortcakes out
there but we're going with the classic
biscuit version with strawberries the
best shortcakes have a flaky but tender
biscuit
that holds delicious fresh fruit and
decadent whipped cream
don't worry it will be very easy to make
let's start off on our strawberries we
want to hold them so that you keep as
much of the berry as possible
it's crucial to use a small sharp knife
to cut around the stem
and remove the leaves then we're going
to cut the larger berries in half or
quarters to try and get all the berries
to be about the same size
you can technically use any fruit that's
in season like peaches
nectarines apricots or cherries any
macerated fruit with sweetened cream and
a buttery biscuit makes for an
effortless but elegant dessert
now we'll macerate the strawberries it's
like marinating but for berries and
fruits
this is a simple process where you add
sugar to gently break down the fruit
other ways to macerate the fruit is with
syrups or spices
you can use things like some fresh mint
nutmeg
cardamom cinnamon thinly sliced
lemongrass freshly grated ginger
some sumac or basil the possibilities
are genuinely endless
you could also use things like vinegars
liqueurs
honey maple syrup or even vanilla these
are all great options for adding some
extra flavor to your fruit
we're going to take our berries a little
further to really enhance the flavor
in addition to the granulated sugar
we're also adding some sumac for a
little extra tang
and a pinch of salt to bring all the
flavors together and we'll stir it to
coat the berries completely
if you don't have any sumac you can
totally add a squeeze of lemon juice for
a similar effect
we're going to let this sit at room
temperature for about 30 minutes
but then we'll refrigerate them until
we're ready to serve up to overnight
you already know we tested a ton of
different types of biscuits
this is our flaky biscuit this dough is
folded and laminated with fat
to create a bunch of flaky layers this
one
is the drop biscuit this dough is gently
mixed
usually with cream and dropped on a
sheet tray for an extra fluffy texture
this is the one i grew up with the
canned biscuit
these guys are a little more dense but
they're super quick and convenient this
is the one we're calling a kneading
biscuit
this method is probably how most home
cooks do it this dough has a little less
butter and a little more liquid to help
bring the dough together
this is an extra tender biscuit without
all the layers
our favorite biscuit this guy right here
it's sort of a hybrid it's flaky and
crispy
but has an extra tender crumb and makes
the ultimate vehicle for our strawberry
shortcake
we're still working on a name for this
one so if you have any ideas
please leave them in the comments below
to make these biscuits
we're going to mix together our
all-purpose flour baking powder
granulated sugar salt and some baking
soda
the all-purpose flour has a lower
protein content which helps create a
tender texture for a light and fluffy
biscuit
we're using a european butter because it
has a higher fat content than american
butter
the additional fat creates a creamier
and more flavorful biscuit
that's what we're looking for irish
butter can be a little more expensive
and it does add a ton of extra flavor
that you may or may not want for your
biscuit
just like any flaky pastry we want our
butter to be cold
in this case ice cold we're going to
freeze our butter and then use a box
grater to cut the butter into the flour
mixture
this will help to distribute the butter
evenly we've talked about it before but
it's super crucial to only use your
fingertips to gently toss the butter
into the flour mixture
until all of the butter is completely
coated
then we'll pour in the buttermilk and
use one of our favorite tools in the
kitchen
this bowl scraper we want to bring the
mixture together until this shaggy mass
forms the dough will still look a little
dry but don't be tempted to add any
extra buttermilk
buttermilk has the perfect balance of
fat and acid for our biscuits
but we also tested dough with sour cream
yogurt
and lavna lavna is a crazy delicious
strained yogurt
they all produced similar textures but
each of them gave an
extra flavor boost if you're up for
trying something a little different
now we're going to pour the dough onto
our clean surface and use a bench
scraper to help press it into a small
square
a flexible bowl scraper and a metal
bench scraper are great additional tools
for your kitchen
they really help keep the biscuits and
your station clean
once we bring our dough into a really
rough rectangle
we're going to use a rolling pin and
press and roll the dough
once we roll the dough out into a
flatter rectangle
we want to fold it in thirds like a
letter then we'll roll it out again
we're going to repeat this folding and
rolling for a total of four or five
folds
this folding technique is similar to
laminating dough for croissant-like
layers
only it's much more rustic when creating
flaky layers for biscuits
once we've worked in all of our folds we
want to carefully transfer the dough to
a parchment lined sheet tray
and freeze it for about 30 minutes this
will allow the flour
to really hydrate and ultimately help
the biscuits bake evenly
once the dough is fully chilled we'll
bring it back to our cutting board and
use a large chef's knife to trim the
edges and create clean sides
this step is totally optional we're
doing this for the
stunning visual but you can definitely
keep the edges they might not just get
as much rise in the oven
if you do trim the edges be sure to bake
them off for snacking later
then we want to cut the dough in half
and then into thirds so that we have six
mostly even sized biscuits then we're
gonna place the biscuits
back on the baking sheet keeping them
about two inches apart
we're going to brush the tops with heavy
cream and sprinkle with some turbinado
sugar for an extra crispy top
the heavy cream is going to enhance that
stunning golden brown color on top and
also helps our sugar to adhere to the
biscuits
if you don't have any more heavy cream
you can also brush them with some melted
butter
a beaten egg or even a little buttermilk
as an alternative
we want to bake the biscuits until they
rise and are perfectly golden brown
around the edges which should take about
20 minutes
in a 375 degree fahrenheit oven or 190
degrees celsius
then we want to remove the biscuits from
the oven and immediately brush the tops
of each biscuit with some honey
these biscuits are not just texturally
incredible they're also
layered with flavor if you don't think
you'll
eat them all in a day you can cut the
dough and bake as many as you'd like
then wrap the remaining unbaked dough
and freeze up to a month
make sure that the unbaked biscuit dough
is stored in the freezer
storing it in the fridge may cause the
dough to oxidize and discolor
now we're going to move on to our
chantilly cream sure
you can use an easy canned whipped cream
but why not make your own chantilly
it even sounds fancier chantilly is
basically a sweet and whipped cream
and here's our favorite way to make it
we'll mix together our heavy cream and
rooibos
tea steeping our heavy cream with tea is
a great way to enhance the flavor
without changing the texture of our
cream
or adding any additional sweetness now
we want to refrigerate the cream to
steep for at least two hours but up to
overnight
we're gonna pour our steeped cream
through a fine mesh strainer set over a
tall and narrow container
once we pour the cream through we're
going to discard the used tea leaves
now we're going to add the powdered
sugar to the cream
and use a stick blender to bring the
cream together
until medium stiff peaks form the
immersion blender creates an amazing
texture
it's straight up like a fluffy cloud of
sweet cream
you can whisk the cream by hand to get
luscious whipped cream it just takes a
lot more physical labor
you can also obviously whip the cream
with an electric hand mixer but it can
be a little messy
when whipping your own cream make sure
not to overdo it because there's always
the possibility of over mixing the cream
and turning it into butter
but when you whip cream correctly and
get perfect velvet peaks it makes the
most decadent whipped cream that works
perfectly for our strawberry shortcake
on to the final part assembly so we're
going to split the biscuit in half
we're going to spoon a generous amount
of chantilly cream over the top
and then we'll finish it with our
perfectly macerated strawberries
definitely remember to drizzle that
delicious sauce over the top
tada easy piece of shortcake
looks beautiful it's light fluffy
sweet juicy soft and flaky
everything you could ever want in a
dessert
it may be a shortcake but it's
definitely big in flavor
enjoy and stay sweet
oh yes
[Music]
you